the FBI has joined police in South
Carolina in a desperate search for a
missing six-year-old girl Faye Marie
sweat lick has was last seen Monday
afternoon playing in her front yard
investigators have released this video
showing her getting off a school bus
just before she disappeared Janet
shamlian is in KC South Carolina Janet
do police have any leads at this point
Anthony police have received more than
80 tips including doorbell video but
none of those leads have brought Fay
home this morning the search is
expanding here and authorities are now
looking for two cars seen in the area at
the time in hopes that the drivers can
help with the investigation this is six
year old face sweating as she got off
her school bus Monday the first grader
was last seen that afternoon playing in
the front yard of her home where she
lives with her mom and grandmother
that's the biggest law enforcement
operation I've ever seen
sergeant Evan Antley says more than 300
police officers and FBI agents are
blanketing the neighborhood going
door-to-door for clues why can't it be
an Amber Alert Amber Alerts are a little
different we have to have specific
information that she was abducted at
this point we have not ruled out that
faith could have wandered into the woods
playing gotten lost and has not found
her way back home yet they've blocked
off the subdivision from where Fay
disappeared only residents can come and
go and last night detectives released
these photos in search of the drivers of
these two cars nearby when Fay
disappeared an emotional time for
parents here well everyone is praying
constantly everyone that I know it's
just
she's worried sick Lindsay Vonn son
Beckham is friends with Fay at school do
you think he grasps the enormity of
what's going on um kind of actually he's
been nervous about being in the yard
he's been nervous about walking the
doors so I think just all the talk of
possibly someone hurting her has really
affected him friends and neighbors have
met at a nearby church to pray for faith
safe return her grandmother and a family
friend who didn't want to be on camera
safe Fay has a smile that would melt
your heart there are pictures of fate
all over town police cars here driving
up and down residential streets and
occasionally the buzz of a helicopter
overhead for this softball community
life is very far from normal
Tony and for that family as well that's
a real hard story to go through Janet
thank you very much